what's going on Wolfgang today I want to
talk about something that actually
happened a very long time ago about a
year ago actually but I think it's
something that people feel was never
actually addressed in a vendor's
infinity war so it will probably be
addressed in Avengers for just a quick
reminder about the infinity war blu-ray
giveaway that I'm doing all I have to do
to enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts on the video and your favorite
superhero what is your job exactly
besides making balloon animals
okay so does anybody remember this clip
I know who her new BFF is and I can't
tell you I can't but I can I promise you
it's it's brilliant and unexpected and
just so good okay frenemy oh I think oh
I don't know about any frenemies I mean
she's on a clear mission as everybody is
to deal with someone with a glove and I
think that that's you know the most
important issue so I think people are
grouping together to take care of this
task so whether you've seen it before or
this is your first time seeing it let me
ask you who is her new BFF
you might right away say Gamora but they
didn't really have any screen time
together in Avengers infinity war except
for when Gamora was being tortured and
not to mention she said it was
unexpected and I think we could all
expect Gamora and nebula to kind of
rekindle their friendship slash
sisterhood so that's not really
unexpected again she says it's brilliant
and unexpected and so good who is she
talking about here okay let's just break
it down real fast let's ask ourselves
does she have a BFF and Avengers
infinity war no she doesn't
the first time we see her is when she's
being tortured by Thanos the next time
we see her is when she arrives on Titan
and that's pretty much all the screen
time that she gets so when she's being
tortured by Thanos she's alone
yes Gamora comes for a little bit but I
would not classify that as
of BFF and not to mention at the end she
says that they're teaming up so there's
not really much of a team up here Gamora
is just really trying to save her sister
from being tortured and killed so I
wouldn't count that but then she goes to
Titan once she's on Titan she is with
the guardians of the galaxy Iron Man
spider-man and Doctor Strange but she
shows up to the party late and again I
don't think she becomes so-called BFFs
with anyone in this scene there is the
scene where nebula and star-lord find
out that Diana's killed Gamora now you
could consider this bonding between a
sister and a long-term booty call but I
don't think it qualifies for BFF status
and that's pretty much all of the scenes
in Avengers infinity war that have to do
with nebula and other people so I don't
think this has happened yet in Avengers
infinity war I think it's going to
happen in Avengers 4 and who do I think
it's going to be Tony Stark huh did you
hear what I said there is one final
scene in Avengers infinity war with
nebula and that is after the snap where
everybody's gone and it's just nebula
and Tony Stark left alone on Titan this
sort of sets them up to work together
obviously Tony captain and everybody is
going to be super devastated that they
failed they couldn't stop Thanos and he
did the snap and half of the universe
got wiped away from existence
and obviously they're not going to be
okay with this they're not going to
accept it they're going to find a way to
undo it and that's why we have Avengers
for keep in mind at the in scene of
Avengers infinity war with nebula and
Tony Tony does not know who nebula is
she showed up mid-fight she didn't meet
Tony she didn't meet spider-man or
Doctor Strange she just showed up so
Tony's going to ask her who she is and
he's going to find out that she's the
daughter of Thanos Tony will use this he
will find out everything that he
possibly can from nebula about Thanos
and the Infinity stones and it seems
like nebula has had a change of heart
now especially since her sister is now
killed and she still hates Thanos and
her ultimate goal is to kill him so I
bet she'll be pretty cooperative with
the remaining heroes that are left in
trying to help them find a way to undo
the snap not to mention she's kind of
stuck with Tony right now on Titan every
mashup that Tony Peter and Doctor
Strange used to get to Titan is
destroyed the ship that nebula used is
destroyed and we can pretty much assume
star-lord ship is destroyed as well
because Thanos kind of threw a moon at
Titan so they have to figure out a way
to escape together and even if star
lordship is still there they still have
quite a long trip back to earth so
plenty of bonding time
so Tony Stark and nebula becoming BFFs
I'm here for this and if you go back to
what Karen Gillan said this is brilliant
and unexpected and to me it is so good
and not to mention they are both
insanely smart obviously I'm not saying
nebula is as smart as Tony but don't
forget that nebula is super super
trained by Thanos himself who is also a
genius so I'm thinking these two could
probably cook up some pretty good ideas
I actually think that nebula is going to
play a huge part in to helping the
remaining heroes figure out a way to
undo the snap Thanos gave nebula and
Gamora the task of finding out where the
Infinity stones were and as we saw in
Avengers infinity war from the hologram
recording from nebula her and Gamora
have talked about danos collecting the
Infinity stones
not to mention nebula
knows that the soulstone was on Vermeer
so if the Avengers go back in time and
try to collect the Infinity stones if
they don't know where any of them are
nebulae will or if they go the route of
Tony making his own Infinity stones and
Infinity Gauntlet he's definitely going
to need to know what nebula has learned
about the Infinity stones over time I
think this works and I also think it's
going to be pretty funny to see if it
does happen because if you think about
it
nebula and Tony aren't that different
they're both really smart people who
think everybody else is idiots
Walker invited to my wedding so they
would both probably clash heads in a
funny way but they probably also agree
on a lot of funny things as well this is
just a theory of my own this video of
Karen Gillan talking about this
resurfaced and it got me thinking well
hey we never really solved that in
Avengers infinity war so I think it's
going to happen in Avengers 4 and it got
me thinking who it could be
I personally think it's set up to where
it's going to be Tony Stark and I think
it sort of needs to be because Tony is
clearly the key to discovering time
travel along with ant-man
and nebula knows so much about Thanos
and the Infinity stones I think they
need to be paired up I think that that's
you know the most important issue but
what do you think let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments
below and if you think it's going to be
somebody else let me know who you think
it's going to be and why and another
reminder about the Avengers infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts on the video and your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]